♪ ♪
KANYE WEST CAUSED A STIR BY
TWEETING PRAISE OF BLACK
CONSERVATIVE CANDACE OWENS.
THE SMEARS THAT FOLLOWED PROVED
HIS POINT.
THE THOUGHT POLICE WANT TO
SUPPRESS FREEDOM.
CONDEMNING QUEST FOR LIKING
SOMEONE WITH "ANTIBLACK
POSITIONS."
A COWARDLY JOB AT OWENS.
JOY REID MOCKED THOSE LAUDING
THE BRAVERY, REVEALING JEALOUSY
OF OWEN.
TOM ARNOLD.
HE UNLEASHED A SEXIST ATTACK ON
CANDACE.
WE CAN'T SHOW YOU THE TWEET.
HERE IS CANDACE ON
"FOX & FRIENDS" DISCUSSING IT.
>> I THINK IT'S PRETTY TYPICAL
OF THE LEFT.
THE TRUTH IS THE LEFT WANTS TO
STRAP BLACK PEOPLE TO THIS IDEA
THEY ARE VICTIMS.
THAT'S WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO.
THEY DON'T WANT BLACK PEOPLE
FOCUSED ON THE FUTURE.
THEY WANT THEM FOCUSED ON THE
PAST.
THEY WOULD LIKE BLACK PEOPLE TO
BE GOVERNMENT DEPENDENT.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT KANYE WEST
AND MYSELF REPRESENTED THE BLACK
COMMUNITY AND THAT MAKES THEM
VERY NERVOUS.
>> Greg: THESE ATTACKS ON HER
PROOF THAT WHAT KANYE DID WAS A
BIG DEAL.
HE CHALLENGED THE MOB.
HE KNEW THE TWEET WOULD ATTRACT
PITCHFORKS BUT HE DID IT ANYWAY.
HE SACRIFICED HIMSELF TO THE MOB
TO SHOW IT'S POSSIBLE AND IT'S
INSPIRATIONAL.
AS FOR THE ATTACKS, THE GOAL IS
TO STIGMATIZE.
SMEARS SHUTDOWN DEBATE.
WEST MUST BE PUNISHED FOR THE
STRATEGIES TO RUIN EVERYONE BY
CONNECTION.
IF YOU LIKE CANDACE, YOU ARE
WORSE THAN CANDACE.
IN REALITY THEY BOTH TRANSCEND
THE ORBIT THEIR CRITICS STILL
LIVE IN.
KANYE IS EXTRA DANGEROUS TO THE
LEFT.
BLACKS LEANING RIGHT, HE IS
CONFIRMATORY.
AFTER SHUT THEM DOWN.
HE DIDN'T EVEN ENDORSE CANDACE'S
BELIEFS.
JUST HER GUTS.
IN ATTACKING HIM, THEY ARE
ATTACKING THE VERY CONCEPT OF
FREE SPEECH.
THERE IS NOTHING SCARIER TO A
LEFTIST THAT A FREETHINKER.
WEST IS ONE, SO IS OWENS.
NETWORKS SHOULD HIRE HER.
KATIE, I WILL ROOM WANT TO READ
YOU A COUPLE TWEETS.
>> Katie: ARE PROBABLY
RETWEETED A FEW OF THEM.
>> Greg: "DEMONIZATION HAS
METASTASIZED.
WE HAVE FREEDOM OF SPEECH BUT
NOT FREEDOM OF THOUGHT."
TO PARAPHRASE IT, I THINK HE HAS
TAKEN THE RED PILL.
>> Katie: MAYBE THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENED.
WHEN HE SAYS I LIKE HOW CANDACE
OWEN THINKS, THOUGH WITH THE
LEFT HAS RESPONDED TO IT WITH
THE THOUGHT POLICE AND THE
AGGRESSIVE NATURE OF WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN SAYING.
TERRIBLE PERSON, CAN'T BELIEVE
YOU WOULD DO THIS.
HORRIBLE THREATS QUITE FRANKLY
AGAINST CANDACE AT ONCE FOR WHAT
SHE SAID.
THEY ARE PROVING HIS POINT.
THEY ARE PROVING EXACTLY WHAT HE
IS SANE.
THERE IS NO DIVERSITY OF
THOUGHT.
WE CAN'T HAVE A DIVERSITY OF
OPINION.
PEOPLE CAN'T BE WHO THEY ARE IN
THE PROBLEM FOR THE LEFT IS WHEN
PEOPLE LIKE CANDACE OWENS SPEAK
OUT, THEY DEBUNK THE NARRATIVE
THAT YOU HAVE TO BE ALL ABOUT
IDENTITY POLITICS.
THE REPUBLICANS HATE YOU BECAUSE
YOU HAVE A CERTAIN COLOR OF SKIN
OR BECAUSE YOUR WOMAN.
SHE'S A THREAT TO THEM AND SHE'S
GETTING A LOT OF ATTENTION WHICH
IS A VERY GOOD THING.
>> Greg: KIMBERLY, ALSO
TWEETED A TON OF SCOTT ADAMS
VIDEOS.
IT'S ALL COMING TOGETHER, ISN'T
IT?
FOR ME.
I'M IN THE EYE OF THE STORM.